do you uh can you share some of the
Insight because I feel like gun is
somebody who
um is influencing influencing a lot of
culture and Hip-Hop whether or not
people wouldn't acknowledge it
um he's very smart he's a master curator
of course he's an incredible rapper as
well but just in terms of just like his
marketing prowess his business prowess
like what are some of the things that
you were able to pick up from him since
recent like since again coming to
Griselda officially
um just watching
um
watching the moves that he makes
watching how he knows how to like
cultivate you know artwork and you know
Bridget with the music knowing like his
influence like over the Griselda fans
and how like they're very big on just
the suspense the
um the merch you know like those are all
things that like a lot of new age people
aren't really doing and me as a woman
and as an entrepreneur like that's
always motivation because I I want to
take what he's doing and take it even
further you know what I'm saying and
even do it my way because I'm a woman I
don't see no woman moving like that so I
want to be like the female yeah there
really is no woman that's like taking
advantage I mean obviously if Nikki
drops a sweater people buy it like she's
got fans that are you know interesting
um but like I feel like there I haven't
seen like a
a female MC really like dive into the
merch [ __ ] like
some male people have like Tech N9 or
Griselda or whatever so it's wide open
for you for sure facts yeah uh how much
like obviously uh each album is uh a
painting I wanna I'm not gonna [ __ ] his
name up Isaac pelejo right
um was that because we know that that's
something that uh
gun loves his art I mean I've been to
the store I've seen videos of his crew
in Phoenix because this guy's got
paintings [ __ ] everywhere yeah um was
that like a collaborative idea or did
you just kind of let gun handle cure
rate in the art
um I like gun curate the art
um obviously it was kind of like easier
moving on to the list too because it was
kind of like we're going to continue
with the same makes sense but um you
know the art thing is still something
that I'm like learning about like what
makes things like what makes people want
to buy that you know because everybody
can do art but it's like are you gonna
get people to actually want it is it
going to be like dope is it going to be
understood by people came a long way
from Bath and Body work yes for sure in
the in the in the tub and I didn't want
to be on my first album
that makes sense you know because I feel
like people was going to look at it and
be like this ain't gonna sound like what
I think it's gonna sound like or what it
does does sound like right